Transilvania es algo así como Cataluña pero…
¡Con vampiros!
Tal cual como lo oís.
La tierra que vio nacer al mismísimo Conde
Drácula es hoy el escenario de uno de los
mayores conflictos independentistas de toda
Europa.
Dicho de otra forma, Transilvania es el lugar
perfecto para hacer un especial Halloween
de VisualPolitik.
Y sí, lo sabemos, hemos leído vuestros comentarios.
Queréis que hablemos de Cataluña.
Y ¿Sabéis qué?
¡Lo vamos a hacer!
Es más… estamos preparando la madre de
todos los vídeos.
Se trata de una cosa tan grande que nos está
llevando meses de trabajo y que no verá la
luz hasta principios del año 2018.
Mientras tanto, vais a tener que esperar.
Pero os aseguro una cosa… va a dar mucho
de que hablar.
Por el momento, volvamos a Transilvania, que
pese a estar en mitad de Rumanía, casi el
20% de su población no habla la lengua de
Emil Cioran.
El húngaro es su lengua materna.
En algunas zonas, los húngaros superan el
80% de la población.
Concretamente, esta área donde los magiares
son mayoría, se le conoce como Szekely Land,
la tierra de los Szekelys.
Los que seguís VisualPolitik desde el principio,
ya sabéis que los szekelys no están, precisamente,
orgullosos de pertenecer a Rumanía.
En el primer vídeo que publicamos en este
canal ya os dimos unas pinceladas de lo que
ocurre en este lugar.
Que, por cierto, menuda diferencia con los
vídeos que hacemos ahora.
“Hay que resaltar que TRANSILVANIA es la
zona más rica de Hungría… perdón de Rumanía.
Osea que es un tema
muy complejo y muy interesante que seguro
que nos dará pie para otros vídeos…”
Lo cierto es que prácticamente todos los
años se producen manifestaciones masivas
que exigen autonomía
para esta región.
Manifestaciones que se celebran en las principales
ciudades transilvanas, pero también en Bucarest
y… ¡En Budapest, la capital de Hungría!
¡Pero esperad un momento porque la cosa es
más compleja de lo que parece!
Oficialmente, los szekelys no quieren tener
su propio país sino, simplemente convertirse
en una autonomía dentro de la propia Rumanía
con unas condiciones fiscales muy especiales
que os explicaré más tarde.
Así que la pregunta es ¿Por qué esto supone
tantísimos problemas con Rumanía?
¿Por qué estas reivindicaciones han escalado
a la categoría de conflicto diplomático?
Y lo que es más importante ¿Qué pinta el
gobierno de Hungría en todo esto?
Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas.
Pero antes… vamos a ver un poco de historia.
CON PELOS EN LA LENGUA
Durante siglos, Transilvania formaba parte
del reino de Hungría.
Por aquellos años, Rumanía ni siquiera existía
como país.
La nobleza y las clases altas se entendían
en húngaro.
Y el rumano era un idioma relegado a las clases
más bajas y, en muchos casos, perseguido
por las propias autoridades.
Este proceso al que llamamos MAGIARIZACIÓN
consistía en imponer la cultura húngara
a cualquier coste.
Para esas clases altas, los rumanos eran unos
palurdos, amigos de lo ajeno y con un sentido
un tanto discutible de la higiene personal.
De hecho, existe un término en húngaro para
referirse a los rumanos; Szőrös nyelvu que,
literalmente, significa “con pelos en la
lengua”.
Durante el siglo XIX, el gobierno cerró periódicos
que hablaban en rumano y hasta obligó a muchos
ciudadanos a que se cambiaran el nombre.
Sin embargo, las cosas cambiaron al terminar
la I Guerra Mundial.
El imperio Austro húngaro perdió.
Y una de las cosas que te pasan cuando pierdes
una guerra, es que te quitan partes de lo
que antes era tu país.
En el caso de los húngaros, perdieron casi
la mitad de su territorio.
Y una de esas partes fue Transilvania, que
se anexionó a Rumanía.
De repente, esos campesinos, esos szőrös
nyelvu, que habían estado oprimidos por la
nobleza húngara tenían el poder.
Y querían revancha.
Así es como empezaron los primeros intentos
por parte del Gobierno Rumano para acabar
con la cultura húngara en Transilvania.
Y, creedme, no era tarea fácil.
No olvidéis que aunque este territorio formara
parte de Rumanía, todavía quedaban más
de 1 millón de personas, esos llamados SZEKELIS,
que llevaban generaciones hablando en la lengua
de István Örkény.
Escritor húngaro que, por cierto, os recomiendo
encarecidamente.
Pero cuando las cosas se pusieron realmente
feas fue durante la II Guerra Mundial.
Hungría volvió a elegir el bando equivocado.
Y con la ayuda de Hitler, reconquistaron sus
antiguos territorios y volvieron a dar la
vuelta a las tornas.
Todo esto sirvió para calentar más los ánimos
de los rumano-parlantes.
Así que, en 1945, cuando los Alemanes y todos
sus aliados, incluidos los húngaros, perdieron
la guerra, Rumanía volvió a recuperar Transilvania.
Esta vez, con un Gobierno comunista que tenía
más ganas de venganza que nunca.
¿Os acordáis de este vídeo en el que os
hablaba de la dictadura de Nicolae Ceausescu?
Los que lo hayáis visto ya sabéis que la
Rumanía Comunista fue una especie de Corea
del Norte a la Europea. 1 de cada 30 rumanos
pertenecían a la policía política.
Y no sólo se encargaban de perseguir a aquellos
que criticaban al régimen sino también a
aquellos que se atrevían a hablar húngaro.
De la noche a la mañana, el gobierno cerró
todos sus periódicos y les obligó a hablar
rumano incluso en sus propias casas.
Para que os hagáis una idea, hace años,
yo conocí a una chica de esta zona que se
llamaba Tünde.
Tünde es un nombre húngaro.
Sin embargo, en su carnet de identidad ponía
IOANA que es otro nombre en rumano que no
tiene nada que ver con Tünde.
Es como si te llamaras Pedro y te cambiaran
a Dagoberto.
En otras palabras, que la romanización de
Ceaucescu fue muy parecida a la magiarización
del siglo XIX pero al revés y en proporciones
nachovidalianas.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque la cosa no
termina aquí!
En su intento por destruir hasta el último
vestigio de cultura húngara, el Partido Comunista
Rumano obligó a miles de ciudadanos a que
se instalaran en los territorios de mayoría húngara.
De esta forma, los magiares pasaron a ser
una minoría en ciudades como Oradea o Satumare.
Básicamente, toda la zona que hace frontera
con Hungría,
pasó a ser territorio mayoritariamente rumano.
Sin embargo, hay una zona que consiguió mantener
sus tradiciones y su idioma.
Esa zona se llama SZEKELY LAND.
¡RUMANÍA NOS ROBA!
Por cierto, que esto tan bonito que está sonando
es la música de Alexander, un grupo de rock independiente de Bulgaria.
Si os gusta encontrareis más información en los enlaces de la descripción.
En 1991, Rumanía aprueba su constitución
democrática.
Y en esta constitución se reconoce el derecho
a hablar húngaro.
Pero, como os podéis imaginar, tras décadas
de odio hacia el gobierno de Bucarest, estos
szekelys no se quedaron contentos.
¡Pero no sólo eso!
Veréis, desde el punto de vista fiscal, Rumanía
es un país muy centralizado.
Casi todos los impuestos se cobran desde el
gobierno central, que luego reparte el dinero
entre las distintas regiones, principalmente
las más pobres.
Y eso deja en una muy mala posición a Transilvania,
que tiene un nivel de vida mucho más alto
que otras partes del país.
Así es como surgió un nuevo partido político,
la Alianza Democrática de los Húngaros de Rumania,
también conocido como la UDMR.
Y seguro que no os sorprende si os digo que
este partido arrasa en las elecciones en esas
partes de Transilvania donde los húngaros
son mayoría ¿Y cuales son los principios
de esta formación?
Pues, básicamente, dicen que Rumanía les
chupa la sangre… y el dinero ¿Os suena
de algo esta historia?
Pues esperad porque esta no es el único parecido.
Su solución para acabar con el “expolio”
rumano es… nada más y nada menos que imitar
el foro vasco y navarro.
Literalmente.
Los que veáis este vídeo desde España ya
sabéis que el País Vasco y Navarra son dos
comunidades con un régimen fiscal distinto
al del resto del país.
En esas regiones, los ciudadanos no pagan
sus impuestos directamente a Madrid
sino a sus diputaciones forales
Una vez han recaudado el dinero, están obligados
a dar un porcentaje pactado al Estado central,
pero el resto lo pueden gestionar como les
parezca.
Pues bien, esta es la solución que proponían
los Szekelys para su región en el año 2014.
¿Y a que no adivináis lo que les respondió
el gobierno de Bucarest?
¡Exacto!
Que es inconstitucional.
La constitución de Rumanía reconoce, en
su artículo primero, que son un soberano,
unitario e IN-DI-VI-SI-BLE.
Todo esto genera protestas multitudinarias
en distintas ciudades, intentos de hacer referéndums
y todo tipo de actos simbólicos donde se
ondea la bandera de Szekelyland y se canta
el himno Szekely.
Actos que sientan especialmente mal entre
la clase política rumana…
“El partido del gobierno en Rumanía amenaza
a los autonomistas hungaro-transilvanos con
la prisión.
Las maniobras políticas que amenacen el orden
constitucional en Rumanía serán castigadas
con la prision”
¡Qué!
¡Cómo os quedáis!
A estas alturas pensaréis que la historia
de Transilvania y la de Cataluña son prácticamente
idénticas ¿Verdad?
Pues esperad porque todavía no habéis visto
nada…
¿AUTONOMÍA O ANEXIÓN?
Si alguno de vosotros ha estado alguna vez
en Hungría, seguro que habrá visto a alguien
llevando una camiseta con este mapa.
Esta imagen representa la forma que tenía
Hungría antes de perder parte de sus territorios
en la I Guerra Mundial.
Todavía hoy, en pleno siglo XXI, muchos húngaros
sueñan con recuperar su antiguo imperio.
Entre ellos, su presidente, Viktor Orban.
Viktor Orban es algo así como el Vladimir
Putin del Danubio.
Al igual que el presidente ruso, Orban es
famoso por perseguir a los periodistas que
le critican, discriminar a los homosexuales
y ganar elecciones con resultados que superan
el 60% del voto.
“Además, Viktor Orbán tuvo también el
coraje de promover una constitución para
Hungría, que reconocía el catolicismo del
país, defendía al bebé, al feto antes del
nacimiento, identificaba los valores nacionales
del país… algo que llamaba poderosamente
la atención…”
Y, por supuesto, como buen putinista, a Orban
le gusta mandar no sólo en su país sino
también en los de al lado.
“Orban apoya la autonomía de los Szekelys”
Ya sé lo que estáis pensando ¿Por qué
se debería inmiscuir el gobernante de un
país en cuestiones de política doméstica
de otro?
En teoría, lo único que buscan los szekelys
es tener más autonomía pero sin dejar de
formar parte de Rumanía ¿Verdad?
Pues… lo cierto es que esos szekelys también
son ciudadanos húngaros.
“Hungría ofrece la ciudadanía a los húngaros
étnicos que viven en el extranjero”
Tal cual como lo oís.
Todos esos húngaros nacidos en Transilvania
tienen doble pasaporte, derecho a ir a las
Universidades de Budapest y hasta derecho
a votar en las elecciones húngaras.
Esto último fue especialmente polémico a
la par que beneficioso para Orban.
Si ya tiene apoyo popular dentro de las fronteras
de Hungría, fuera de estas es una auténtica
rock star.
Para que os hagáis una idea, el 95% de la
diáspora húngara votó a su partido, el
FIDESZ, en las últimas elecciones legislativas.
Un partido que, como os podéis imaginar,
hace que Donald Trump parezca Justin Trudeau.
Mientras tanto, Rumanía considera que estos
derechos de los szekelys son una violación
de su soberanía.
En su opinión, si votas en dos elecciones
a la vez, no puedes mantener tu lealtad al
país en el que vives.
Todo esto significa que las relaciones diplomáticas
entre Hungría y Rumanía son tan lamentables
como útiles para sus respectivos gobiernos.
Orban utiliza a Rumanía como un antagonista
para su propaganda nacionalista.
Y Rumanía no pierde ninguna oportunidad para
chinchar a Hungría en la política Europea.
Y ahora os preguntaréis ¿Y la Unión Europea…
qué dice al respecto?
Pues lo cierto es que, aunque el Consejo de
Europa siempre ha defendido los derechos de
las minorías étnicas, Bruselas no puede
dejar que Hungría se apunte un tanto.
A fin de cuentas, Victor Orban es como el
Drácula, Frankenstein y Freddy Krueger de
los políticos europeos.
Así que, mientras la sangre no llegue al
río, ninguna institución ni político europeo
se va a pronunciar de forma clara al respecto.
Así que ahora la pregunta es para vosotros
¿Os parece que Transilvania debería tener
su propia autonomía dentro de Rumanía?
¿O tal vez no sea más que un intento de
Hungria para recuperar la influencia en sus
antiguos territorios?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Mientras tanto, si queréis conocer más a
fondo lo que está ocurriendo en Rumanía,
el país más corrupto de Europa, podéis
haced click en el vídeo que os vamos a poner
al final.
Como siempre, no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas, así que suscribíos
al canal para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y… ¡Espero que paséis un Halloween, un
día de los muertos y un día de todos los
santos terroríficamente divertido!
Hasta pronto!